mr. white we're gonna watch El Camino
John do it do it John that's right mr.
White's magnets yo science [ __ ]
usually when I ask you to improv you you
go for like 45 mr. Wyatts
we're gonna watch the trailer for El
Camino [ __ ] it's about the guy who
first invented the car El Camino [ __ ]
the Black Keys
yeah reel it in you you pushed me into
the swimming pool yeah then you learn to
doggie swearing and now we got yellow
dog all he said is this is his
catchphrase well that's what
[Music]
[Music]
Wow great
[Music]
excited
[Music]
you suspect
[Music]
you ready
[Music]
and then he goes to jail man you made a
lot of mess of the mood of this trailer
the shots overall yeah looks kind of
like a art house action thriller yes
like one of those crime movies that you
know probably won't have like a ton of
action but when it does it's really
gonna scar well yeah it looks like
there's probably like a couple of key
cool sequences but okay Watson we got a
cat and love Breaking Bad but for the
most part II know it's gonna be it's
gonna be Breaking Bad sighs it's gonna
be dramatic it's gonna be intense what I
love about this concept is that when
Vince Gilligan with both better call
Saul and Breaking Bad but he wants to
create a ticking clock to any of the
episodes or the seasons it is just
gratifyingly suspenseful the movie it's
just this giant escape against the clock
oh man that it's gonna be freakin wild
man yeah and you know like I thought
about it cuz I mean this movies first
announced I was like yeah I really want
this film I know better call Saul is you
know a pretty incredible show so they
did a great job with doing a spin-off
prequel of sorts Breaking Bad is with my
favorite drama of all time I've seen the
whole series twice and I was like but
then it kind of end perfectly and then I
thought about well actually you know
what yeah Jesse this it goes off in the
distance not to interpretation but he's
Emily's a fugitive at this point into
the night but that's hardly Jesse being
out of the woods yet yeah it's like it's
so gratifying to see him free at the
very end but yeah you got to imagine
that this guy's life is going to be a
lot more difficult before it gets a lot
more easy yeah so you had to see him
back with badger and skinny Pete and
just how horrible it looks like he feels
and looks and especially you know piggy
backing it's been a long time since
Breaking Bad ended and yeah it's so
tangible how we like you flash right
back to those circumstances at the end
because Jesse arguably gets it the worst
out of anybody like a tall order to come
back to Breaking Bad after so long but
looking at what they did with better
call Saul and how invested they are in
their characters I think this could be
really interesting and this could add a
flavor because Jesse's got its so
destroyed by this point yeah man I mean
Andrea and Brock were a killed and we
never got to see his they have a photo
that you do see here brilliantly you
never really get to have the grieving
elements of what happens when you lose
the two people that you care about so
much that's the thing it's like he got
free from being a prisoner but there's
still an arc to his character that I can
see being left undone you know it's like
his relationship with Walter White is
done obviously but his own personal
journey it's like yeah the fact that
he's a fugitive does count but you know
it's like he does he really it's not
like you just you know break free and
then home free I'm looking to the
Caribbean you know now you return to
being a human being at all and yeah I
mean I'm hoping that's what they explore
and I have no reason to suspect that
they won't I mean just because Breaking
Bad had such a perfect balance of really
intensive grossing plotting but also
really affecting character words I'm
curious if this will actually really
work only because I have like a 99.9
percent faith that it'll work my point 1
percent is that Vince Gilligan's great
storytelling has come in the medium of
television and this is a movie while I
think there's like incredible bottle
episodes and just episodes of both
Breaking Bad and better call Saul of
that just like that well actually no I
take it back
I think it's gonna work because he's
Vince Gilligan did say this movie is
very much designed for people who
followed Breaking Bad didn't think he
could successfully make this if he was
trying to reintroduce or you know get
new people onboard yeah he said that he
just had to do the right story and just
make it for the faint like it's the only
way you'll be able to truly grasp this
is if you watch Breaking Bad yeah make
it for the people who are truly invested
I'm nervous about this because - it does
seem like a lot of guys for really great
TV show runners do have trouble
transitioning and to just feature film
territory I can think of Matthew whiner
know a holly guys who have made great TV
who have had some trouble with film but
you know this YAG this doesn't give me
much to outwardly worry about other than
that little statistic yeah yeah it's a
point 1 percent yeah yeah and just
yeah again at the mood of this and
everything yeah seems pretty natural and
I really really surprises up their sleep
I saw the teaser trailer the one where
they're interviewing oh my god Guinea
Pete skinny Pete yeah yeah skinny Pete
at the police station and it was like
this little Emmys trailer and all
they've been teasing and even with here
this is like the official trailer and
all they've been teasing is mood and you
know possible scenarios it's like yeah
they've made it really clear jesse is a
fugitive on the run from the from the
police FBI whatever and everyone and
then he's also got a lot of trauma to
overcome yeah and that's all we've
gotten so far I love that because we
really don't know where this movie's
gonna go we don't know what's going to
happen I wonder if they're gonna have
like a main cop character you know and I
really like the head of the hunt any one
of those characters you cut back and
forth between the title especially makes
me wonder for a weird reason because I
can just in dialogue chatter I can hear
like it's such a unique type of car and
it's something they would definitely be
tracking and that's one of those things
you would hear on a list of police you
know things to keep an eye out for
things that are gonna make you
immediately noticeable yeah so this just
has an aesthetic of like yeah there's
probably gonna be police on his tail and
it's probably gonna play on that messed
up thing of why you'll probably
sympathize with the cop character
because they're doing their job but we
also know all the stuff Jesse's been
through and probably how misunderstood
is gonna be by those cop characters and
I imagine that you know maybe some gray
area can come out of there too you know
I'm just excited that we have this
anticipation to choose yeah and that
they've taken this approach to
advertising and I'm sad for Aaron Paul
he hasn't had any work that has exceeded
with Jesse Pinkman character horse look
at that horse yeah yeah definitely
everyone knows it for the well he's done
he's done other things in between that
had been well-received absolutely
something's like greatly received I
heard a lot of good about the path but
we haven't had you know some he did like
Need for Speed that's what I remember I
I enjoyed that that was good but I have
a great which features Oscar winner Ram
- Grammy Malik kid cudi isn't it uh and
if we could get a sequel we should just
throw an El Camino right in there that's
perfect I wonder if there will be
flashbacks to characters like Mike or
Kristen using major characters are all
coming back all right guys well are you
excited for El Camino as a stupid
question what are your hopes for El
Camino are you watching the theaters if
it's playing in a location near you
comment below you guys can subscribe or
the real rejects please click that
notification bell again notify whenever
we got a YouTube video well can check us
out on patreon where we do weekly Q&A s
TV show reaction stream alongs sync up
and some shows have reaction highlights
included so you don't have to worry
about doing the syncing and he does
music video coverage weekly maybe we'll
cover this for patreon yeah like a music
video yeah what I want to do is just sit
here oh yeah we got to do this and then
BTS burden stage just movie reactions
before we wrap this up I would like to
give a page for the day shout out to a
man named Josh Walker it's been like 2
to 3 months since I've heard back from
you dude I don't understand why people
pledge I start talking with them and
then they ghost me you're like the 18th
person this month who is ghosting me
maybe people get off on watching you
Riggle say Josh I looked up your name
and teens yahweh is salvation' or to
save and your last name Walker Texas
Ranger it means to roll turn and full
cloth so that's cool yeah I got nothing
Old English well Sheehan names I guess
yep got nothing
that's I just I do you probably don't
even know the name of the meaning of
your name so there you go it's a gift